this
is star talk cosmic queries edition
co-host chuck nice check hey hey neil
what's happening
feeling good today absolutely man it's a
great day to be doing star talk
okay what is going on outside for you to
say that i just wonder
it's cause the sun is shining because
we're having a little
we're having a little battle locust here
no i think the real answer is every day
is a good day today that's
exactly the real thing that's the real
deal so today's cosmic aquarius
are they're all based on the moon really
and i know a little bit about the moon
you know a little bit but being modest
no no no
i know it as an astrophysical object
okay i don't want more wait a minute
what what more is there it's an
astrophysical lobster no no no that is
what you do
like yes however it's also a
geological object
so people who think about rocks and
minerals and
and igneous rocks
and cratering they're people who have
that expertise and that's who we have on
this show
right now raquel nunez recall welcome to
start hello
such an honor to be here thank you for
having me excellent
excellent and so you are a doctoral
candidate
at ucla and uh university california los
angeles right that's what
that stands for and so how much does
your mother pay
somebody will get you in there
what did your mom lie about us
ucla was on the list it's my daughter
she's an archer
[Laughter]
so okay well i guess we'll find out
chuck what kind of expertise she
actually has
um so you're you're in the department of
earth and planetary sciences
excellent and uh your doctoral candidate
so
we expect your phd in within a couple
years perhaps
hopefully within the next year my my
advisor told me he wants me out by june
so
oh yeah well that works
i keep having babies during grad school
so it's delayed the process a little bit
but i think he's he's like you're ready
just just well if you get into the world
during graduate school and you
successfully graduate graduate school
then you got that done
right and now you by the way yeah
you get something called degree plus
so that's right it's got to be something
yeah you get extra
you get a p you get a phd
plus i like that disney plus and all you
guys right
well congratulations on pulling all that
off and
but just in particular uh you know to
the astrophysicist and to the biologist
the moon is just kind of a dead place
and it's and it's you know
it's just there's no color it's and
and yet this is the subject of your phd
thesis
so what's up with that what do you see
that we don't see
so it is my goal to change your mind
with this thank you thank you cosmic
query
episodes
so it actually turns out that we don't
know very much
about the moon we know something but um
we still don't know how
it formed we think we know but it it's
not a solved case
and so what's really interesting to me
is i've always
looked at the moon you know we see it
and when we go at night we see the moon
and it's beautiful
so it's always been a thing for me to
appreciate and i think that's what's so
appealing for me
the moon is that i i've seen it ever
since i was a child
and just wonder like what is it is there
are there beings on there but of course
there's not there's there's no life on
the moon
um but um it's
it's something that has been with the
earth since the
almost since the beginning of the earth
so everything that the earth has
experienced
essentially the moon has witnessed and i
like to think of the moon as a witness
plate
to what has happened here on earth and
that's what's so exciting
can i get a witness yes right
hello i'm the moon i like to watch
so so raquel you make a fascinating sort
of point
of scientific romance where you have an
object of interest that you study
and when you go home there it is in the
sky oh yeah just and it's there to
remind you
to come back the next day guess because
so much of science involves things you
can't see
it's too far away you need a big
telescope and you have it right there
as this daily
and it's the only place where we've
actually been
yeah yeah but even so that we
hardly know hardly anything we we've
landed in six spots
imagine landing in six spots on earth
and saying yeah i know
we got earth all sewn up you know yeah
but i'm just saying like it's it's it's
kind of cool that we can go
there like i'm surprised that we haven't
gone back more and more
but we can go there is that we once went
there
we don't know how to go there today we
got nothing to get us there
so what why are you serious yes dude
come on what are you working on we can't
go to the moon today
yeah that's why for most of the last 40
years the comment we can go to the moon
but we we can put a man to move we can't
and the answer is we
actually can't any longer put a man on
the moon or anybody on the moon yeah
okay this this show has depressed the
hell out of it okay
well look raquel is here to sort of to
brighten our day
yeah you've got the questions raquel we
solicited questions from our fan base
on our social media platforms chuck has
them i haven't seen them
these are coming out of the blue or out
of the dark
because the universe is not blue it's
just dark so what do you have chuck
so let's get to it let's start off with
patreon we always start with the patreon
patron
because they give us money they pay
that's right pushes them to the front of
the line there you go thanks guys
because that's the american way there
you go
um this is tracy
uh scrub it and she says
what is the most surprising thing we've
discovered from studying the moon rocks
and samples
that we brought back from the moon also
have there been
any unmanned missions to collect more
samples except two
i will answer that second question
because it'll be quick yes there have
been
uh uncrewed uh samples collected from
the moon uh by
ussr so they sent there's three i don't
remember what they were luna
and then a number i don't remember what
number missions they were but they
brought back i think it was about about
a pound of rocks and dust from the moon
moon weight or a pound earth weight
[Laughter]
i see what you did
whereas the apollo missions brought back
i think it was around 900 pounds of rock
so
the the soviet union brought back a very
small amount but if you actually if you
go online and try to buy moon dust
so you can't buy and you can't sell
apollo moon
rocks and dust it's illegal but you can
buy
the uh the soviet collected moon dust
and rocks on the web
somewhere russian right
of course if you have enough money you
can also buy a nuclear warhead from
russia
[Laughter]
so okay that's interesting so i had a
sample return mission i didn't know that
now for the first
question what was it was what was the
most surprising and interesting studying
moon rocks and samples
what did we learn that was absolutely
shocking
so we had no idea how the moon
formed at the time uh this there's a
famous scientist yuri
he believed that the moon was a very
ancient like it was made up of
primordial
dust and rock from the beginning of the
solar system so he thought that just
these rocks had kind of stuck together
and ended up here on the moon so that
nothing had ever happened to the moon it
just bunched a pile of rock from
beginning of the solar system stuck
together um
and but this was actually kind of good
because people wanted to go
to the moon to collect a sample of of
what the solar system
started out to be um why can't we just
do that on earth
oh because it has been processed at the
same time
we did but what has happened is we have
melted
we have we have been completely
reprocessed our surface
of the earth has been completely
reprocessed so that's why when we
when we collect certain types of
meteorites uh they're called chondrites
we're very excited because that is made
up of the the primordial
dust and and particles from the
beginning of the solar system so we can
learn
about what what it looked like when it
when this all started out
because earth is geologically active
that's right contaminates your
the purity of what you see you change it
it becomes different minerals it becomes
yeah completely different and so we
thought that the moon was just this
gigantic piece of primordial
dust and rock and when we
the apollo astronauts went their
collective rocks it turned out that
the moon has had an incredible geologic
history
it has melted the the moon was at some
point
completely melted it was covered in in
magma magma ocean that's what we call it
and come differentiate and ended up
differentiated so the the heavy stuff
sunk to the bottom forming the an iron
core
and then the light material the light
minerals and rocks floated to the
surface and that's what you see
what's the difference between magma and
lava okay
so magma is lava that hasn't erupted
out of of of its source
so you have a different word for where
you find the stuff
right so if it if it comes out of of the
of the surface and becomes lava
uh if it's still trapped underneath and
melted then it's it's magma
that's what we call it so whatever
whatever
geological thing it is once it gives
birth
now it's it gives birth to lava yes so
it goes from being a fetus
that's right that's right um
keeping with the maternity theme
i i just had a baby a month and a half
ago so i got baby
how many kids you have how many kids
three that was my third
three little lavas that's so lovely and
they're spilling all over the house
everywhere everywhere shirts
everywhere um yeah so
so we learned that the the moon has has
had an incredible geologic history it
had been
processed it had been melted and
minerals different types of minerals
formed
um and yeah it
it made us think it made us think about
okay so it didn't form
the way we thought it did so how did it
form
okay so that's so so so
your biggest surprise was not a question
that it answered
it was a question that it left you
not knowing the answer to that's right
and i think that's the most exciting
thing
is when you have more questions when
things don't lead to
the answer and you have more more things
to explore so what are the questions you
got
jack uh here's robert weaver also from
patreon
and robert says my daughters lila and
peyton
would like to know how come the moon has
so many craters and the earth doesn't
have
any um and i'm going to say robert
you tell lila and peyton
to go look it up we're not here to do
their homework
go google it next question
all right i i love that question um
so actually the earth does have craters
so we have about
i think it's about 150 recognized
craters on the surface of the earth
but because like i said the earth is
very geologically active we have
plate tectonics that's causing the
plates to subduct underneath each other
you essentially erase the history of
what has happened in the past on earth
and the other thing we have we have an
atmosphere so
certain rocks if they're small enough
they just burn up in the atmosphere they
never enter
they never hit the ground whereas on the
moon anything that hits it
if it's a large enough size it's going
to create a crater
and then we also have wind which erodes
any evidence of past craters we have
water that also erases evidence and even
life
little critters making their homes
underground
collapse uh crater features here on
earth so that's why we don't see them
we've had them and we have them there's
actually a beautiful crater in arizona
called meteor crater
that formed about 50 000 years ago and
it's one of the best i think it might be
one of the best preserved crater
on earth and you can really you can see
it and it's cool yeah
it preserved not because there was a
preservation society but because it was
in the desert right
that's right there's not much more rain
exactly and it's a geologically dead
area right exactly okay yeah oh that's
super cool
so so the earth is basically a
contaminated crime scene
you can never you never know what's
going on
constantly being bleached
okay you just made me nervous i'm sad
i'm i'm serious i'm like wait a minute
you know what
i know a lot about cleaning up a crime
scene okay i used to be in the military
and i was
i worked i went i worked in a medical
laboratory so i
i know about cleaning cleaning okay all
right cleaning the evidence yes
yes but what you're meaning to
just to summarize i think is if we
didn't have these
cleansing pro these evidence removing
uh processes we would look just like the
moon
that's right just like it ever
everything that
this is what i meant by the moon being
at witness plate is everything that's
the same part of the absolutely exactly
exactly
exactly yeah all right all right chuck
give me some more all right um let's see
here
this is
uh canadian
nope canadian very funny the way they
spelled it this is canadian from patreon
hello neil chuck stop blaming how people
spell things on the fact that you can't
pronounce their names
what else am i going to blame it on
oh this
as much as i put your names i'm telling
you i gotta find a way to
you know i gotta have some excuse
all right hello neil chuck and raquel uh
if future immune missions end up
drilling
into the surface and extracting a core
sample like we do on earth
what do you think we might find how far
down do you believe
the rock layer extends before we start
hitting
cheese
or oil yeah one of the other yeah yeah
right they both have value with
yes right right right very cool yeah
that's i wonder that too raquel oh man
as much as i love
cheese and wish i could eat some moon
cheese uh i
i think we'd have to go pretty far down
to not find it
nice job i like the misdirection i like
that mr brexit
yeah what makes you think the surface
isn't cheesed
there you go but but it turns out there
are layers there are layers
what we find if we actually pull the
core out yes well it depends on how far
you go but
the moon is a differentiated body so
like i said before it's melted and
it's it's been separated the heavy stuff
sank to the bottom and the light stuff's
at the top so
what you have you have a core in the
center you have
your mantle and then you have your crust
like here on earth
just to be clear when people you know we
think of rocks
as heavy things because they go to the
bottom of a pool
but when you think of rocks you think of
light things
because metal things are heavier than
rocks are
that's right or density right that's
there they're more dense so they yeah
you see
the light things floated to the top
they're rocks what they're boulders what
the hell are you talking about
you're right yeah i know that's i have a
very different perspective
because you're a geologist from another
species of person
okay uh but on on top of the crust we
have what's called the regolith so
because the moon has been bombarded by
you know billions of years of rocks
hitting its surface it's broken up
the rocks that were there before and so
there's this powder
uh of dust on the surface that that
it i think it's between five and ten
meters
on top so so it's not a matter of
uh breaking apart the rocks it's like
completely pulverized
pulverizing them yes yes powder
that's right is this the same stuff they
were trying to get they couldn't get off
their
spacesuits that's right so it ends up
being very sharp because there's no
water
or anything to round out the corners the
these fragments are so sharp that when
they stick to you it's like impossible
to get them off
um and we we actually we have samples in
our lab there's people in our lab that
studied
optical properties of the regolith and
um and you can you can
the samples that we got were removed
from the astronauts spacesuits
so they brushed they were trying to save
everything they can
it's such precious material
to get to the moon that's right anything
in the trash can
so when they brought you know the
astronauts came back they got their
suits and and brushed off their dust and
and we actually used that for
scientific research and you can find
little fibers in there
and it's not mixed with their dandruff
or anything
oh man that'd be an interesting thing
it's like
oh you don't use head and shoulders
we're gonna take a quick break when we
come back
more star talk cosmic queries with
raquel nuno
we're back star talk cosmic queries this
episode on the moon
the moon is a geological object not just
a pretty thing in the night time sky
check but we don't mind that we don't
mind that it's a pretty thing in the
united states that's right
that works that works and we have raquel
nuno who's a
doctoral candidate at ucla studying the
moon
coming to it as a geologist and that's a
whole other species of scientists as far
as i'm concerned
because you all see the world very
differently from the astrophysicist
you look at the moon you see rocks on
the moon i look at the moon i just see a
beautiful orb
in the sky that's all i that's that
that's where it ends for me
and then i go to and then i go to mars
to look for life see
so chuck you got more questions
you just made that up you just made that
up nailed it
i don't know what it is man he said i
mean it says it says kevin kala kikamaka
i think
okay and and if it is kevin kawakimaka
then i say uh aloha
okay he says um
uh what is it when the moon
hits your eye like a big pizza pie
no i'm joking he does not say that
he did not say that okay here's what he
says can the
can the moon have a moon
and can that moon
have a moon as well i think this is a
question more for neil but
maybe you know too raquel do are there
any
because this is really kind of a really
interesting question
are there any instances that we find in
the cosmos
where a moon also has its own satellite
so we i don't think we found one yet at
least definitely not in our solar system
but it is theoretically
possible to have a moon of a moon
and there's a paper that came out i
think they called it a sub moon
or moon moon depends on i think there's
a thing on twitter
where people on twitter were like no we
want moon moon because it hasn't been
named officially yet
uh so um but yeah so theoretically you
can have
a moon of a moon but i think what the
problem is
is that you have to have the right
conditions because if
for example i think if it's the moon is
too close
to the parent body like the planet you
can just
just just stabilize its orbit and it
will either spiral out of orbit or
into the planet so neil do do you have
any
more insights about it yeah i agree
entirely yeah it's a matter of
uh i mean just just think it through so
let's say our moon had a moon
right and so it's going around our moon
i think
as it comes to this side earth's gravity
on it will be stronger
much stronger than it is on the other
side so here's this satellite that's
getting
tugged asymmetrically as it's trying to
orbit the moon
and this creates conditions for very
unstable orbits
when you have an unstable orbit your
your future is doomed
either as racquel said to fall into the
earth or to spiral off into infinity
so you need in order to have one of
these three body systems what you would
need
is a very big separation between the
planet and the moon
so that an object can go around that
moon
and not have the difference in gravity
be so great that's what the moon
and earth is relative to the sun right
okay if if earth is a moon of the sun
then the moon is a moon moon of the sun
okay
but that's okay because we're really far
away from the sun so
so so you can do the math on the the
fabric of the of the
stable orbits and you can see where you
can put objects where they can stay
and where you can put objects where
they're unstable so see and now
i am really not that i could do the math
because i couldn't but now i'm just
thinking
how cool would it be to create a solar
system mathematically
where you could actually have a planet
a planet the moon its moon
and they all are in orbit so that the
gravity
pulls just at the right time to keep
everything in balance
like like those plate spinners on the
you know like
dude
it's on the right path though i like
these ideas but it is fun chuck
there are these orbit programs where you
try to create a solar system and you
you might be surprised how hard it is
yeah because you
i want to put a planet here at this
speed nope that's going to fall into the
sun
so there's only a speed that works at a
distance in in whatever is the shape of
the orbit that it has
so uh in fact the solar system uh
correct me if i'm wrong raquel
uh recent models suggest that we might
have started out with as many as 30
planets
in the formation scenario most of which
have spiraled off into interstellar
space
is that about the right number 30 is
that a fair number to use
that rings right and it seems reasonable
but yes that
i think the takeaway is there's more
planets that we don't have that we can
than we currently have
right that are that have been ejected
out ejected out yeah i've seen those
i've seen some of those models where you
ha and they were even closer to the sun
and then once they they kind of jump
places and they get knocked out
everywhere
yeah yeah it's quite quite the unstable
place that's right
we're so lucky we are so lucky it blows
my mind every time i think about it
wow okay all right that is super cool
okay here we go um morgan
tanji also from patreon um
if there's no weather or atmosphere on
the moon
where does the ice come from
oh because we learned about i there's
ice on the moon
so you all just thought you knew
everything but you don't there's ice
there's still so much to learn
we think they're thunderstorms on the
far side you just can't see them
that means that's so cool that would be
cool it would be cool
so what's up with the water on the moon
yeah so there's different
um sources of water on the moon um
they can come from comets and and
meteorites that
bring water to the surface of the moon
um you also have what i think is really
cool is
the sun the so the sun is spewing this
massive
amount of charged particles called the
solar wind
and protons from the solar wind
hit the surface of the moon so hit
oxygen that that's on the rocks
hit the rocks and and bond with oxygen
forming
water like hydrated minerals right the
proton
is the nucleus of a hydrogen atom yes so
it's hydrogen
hydrogen combining with the oxygen in
the rocks
forming hydrated minerals forming water
at the surface of the moon
um and there's actually so wait a minute
is this like water out of thin
space yes that's right yes yes yes yes
yes the water just got conjured it's
just like particles
right it's like wow you're just looking
for the moon to have a wand just like
it's right water that's crazy
yeah and there's actually one other
place that we get water from and that's
actually from the interior of
the moon and we didn't know this until
recently um
they there they did there's these they
call them glass beads they're just
volcanic glasses that from the samples
collected from the apollo by the apollo
astronauts
and when you slice them open and look
inside
you actually find trapped water
molecules
inside those those those glass beads so
that tells you that there is water
there at least in the past when these
when the moon was
geologically active there was water
trapped within the mantle
okay but it gets very hot during the day
why doesn't all that just evaporate
yeah right oh that's a good question so
it does it does sublimate out
chuck i asked a good question you know
what i did a compliment
i didn't want to break up the flow but i
was about to say it better be a good
question
like could you imagine if neil asked a
question and you were like what a crap
ass question
oh my god i'm glad i didn't do it wait
did neil degrasse tyson just ask me that
dumb ass what what
[Laughter]
all right i'm sorry bad question so
um what ends up happening is there's
these
places at the poles these craters at the
poles of the moon so at the top and at
the bottom
um that haven't seen sunlight they're so
deep
and they because of the way that the
moon rotates
they haven't seen sunlight for billions
of years so
it's very cold it actually turns out to
be one of the coldest places in the
solar system actually even colder than
the surface of pluto
and so if water ends up there
it gets trapped essentially forever for
for billions millions of years
and that's where the ice is that's where
where we think that the ice is
is trapped inside these we call them
permanently shattered regions
because they're so cold essentially
nothing can escape rachel you can say it
the water is where the sun don't shine
for that i think so i guess if you're on
the poles the sun never gets very high
in the sky
that's right and so you can have a
crater lip that
permanently shadows because the shadows
are very long by the low
sun that's right and that those pockets
are where you're talking about
that's right so if we're going to have
colonies on the moon and want to use in
situ
resources we've got to have some access
to these to these craters at the poles
in order to get the water and that's a
lot of a lot of mission concept designs
have been to go to these crater rims so
you can
you still have access to sunlight to
power your equipment
and also now you have these permanently
shattered regions where you can go and
collect
the ice that we think is there okay the
moon is sounding a little more
interesting
right i'm not there yet i'm gonna give
it a few more minutes
so now when let's i just have a question
so when you
the water that we're talking about that
uh in the form of ice whether it's
deposited there or
it it it uh just forms
is it is it is it potable is i mean is
it like
is it like is it just water can we drink
it or is it
you know something else so it is water
but it's probably mixed in with
the that regolith that
that's right so you might need to uh
bring some some filters with you if
you're gonna
need some machine to to scoop up the
regolith and have some
you know a spigot at the end but
something's to have to process it
together
that's right because a lot of these is
it true a lot of these are just sort of
isolated or just a few water molecules
yeah it at the surface yes yes it's it's
pretty much
just like a coating on these minerals
that you have some coating of water so
you need to go
to these permanently shattered regions
where we think there's
large amounts of water eyes but we don't
know how much
and and that's actually a really
exciting field of research is is sending
away sending more spacecraft or you know
people try to figure out what what is
happening in these regions
so if i went back to the moon i'd want
to go to near one of those coal traps
and start
around i
[Laughter]
here we go this is bryce
sondag and bryce uh is coming to us from
instagram
and i should bring this over here i'm
talking away from the microphone um
bryce would like to know how are the
rocks and minerals
on the moon any different than the rocks
and the minerals here on earth
and can i can i add a dimension to that
question
so you as a geologist have full
expectations that minerals repeat
right quartz or do whatever you know
whatever your fundamental minerals are
you're pretty sure it's something that
happens universally
at whatever temperature and pressures
that you'd expect
does the biologist should the biologists
have the same confidence
you do that if you find life anywhere
it's going to have dna naturally
because that's how nature makes life
just the same way your quartz has sio2
because that's how nature makes quartz
do you have any insight there or do you
just privilege that your geology repeats
every place you go
that's an interesting question um good
job again
okay just kidding um
so i would i would expect the
the quartz would form the same anywhere
and if it doesn't then we probably end
up calling it something else
it would probably be
right but it turns out so warts
it's warts it's faux quartz
okay um but
when you look at the rocks on the moon
that the apollo astronauts brought back
or even from meteorites that we know
came from the moon
um the moon is actually
so similar to the earth and that's that
was one of the
that was a big question like why why
would the moon why would you expect the
moon to
to be so similar to the earth you
wouldn't you wouldn't at all
and so because they are it has
um it it adds
this element of of curiosity of like
what happened how did the moon form to
to cause that to happen because you
would not expect that at all because if
some
some object came and hit the earth and
you would expect that
the moon would be part of that other
object as well but it's it's not it's
essentially made up of the
earth's mantle uh which is kind of
mind-blowing
so our theories of how the moon form
need to take that into account
but don't they the modern ones some of
them do
but they don't account for everything
yeah it's hard and so now there's these
things
that's hard it is it's really hard
there's all these questions that we
still don't know about the moon and
that's i feel i think that's why it's so
exciting scientifically
okay all right all right uh this is evan
wells from patreon who sees
this dr tyson and dr soon to be
nuno i've been waiting for this talk for
a very long time as i'm a big fan of the
moon
as well as planetary geology do you two
personally believe in thea
is that correct am i saying it right
thia thea
t-h-e-i-a the most logical theory of the
moon's
origin are there any other examples that
you can recall
of the moons that that are exceptionally
close to their planet such as
our moon uh looking at different other
moons in the in the solar system
uh thanks and so much respect uh
from the space coast oh
so down in florida yes uh very excellent
uh that's a really great question which
we don't have time to answer until we
come back
from this break see what i did there i
teased that that's what the
pros do that right sit through the
commercial
uh but of course commercials are what
drives the finances of everything
so anyhow we're going to be right back
star talk cosmic queries the movement
with soon to be dr raquel nuno back with
chuck nice my
goodness jack yes yes and our special
guest today
raquel nuno nuno i feel
i have hispanic background and so to say
nuno feels wrong
i know i hear you struggling with it too
yeah it's so funny
it's so funny because when we went to
break you went
and raquel
you heard that damn i thought i covered
that up no
no so you have a portuguese
root i do yeah that's born raised my
whole family's been there forever so
they don't have an a in portugal no we
don't so if you want to make that sound
it would be an n and then an h
afterwards that's how we make the
sound yeah yeah but my my name is
just nuno with just an n and it's weird
my
this is nuno is of portuguese first name
that my family somehow ends up
ended up with the last name no idea how
that happened
it's like mary mary would be
all right all right when we left off
chuck you there was a question about uh
the hypothetical object thea yeah is
that correct so evan wells wants to know
this do you two personally believe in
thea and the other thing is are there
moons in the solar system
that are like our moon
so um can pro so the whole idea of thea
can we
can you let me in on that yeah sure so
the idea was that a mars-sized object
then which we're calling thea impacted
an early earth
and it was such a massive impact
that sprayed all this material out into
space and that it
condensed out and formed our moon so
that's the idea
so marseille's object called thea hit
the earth
and formed the moon but just to be clear
thea is gone yes yes and so some
became earth and the rest became the
moon and some
scattered wherever else right that's
right that's not wait a minute for this
to happen these
that thing would have to be super super
hot
like you know what i mean no chuck
you'll get hot just from the collection
it gets hot yeah it gets
loud oh yeah you get that for free
oh that's super cool you don't have to
order that okay
great oh okay okay and that's actually
that's what would cause
all that impact so then when the moon
formed and all these
pieces came together um it heated up the
surface of the moon and that's
how we got that magma ocean it
completely melted so
yeah you get energy just from things he
get heat from things hitting each other
wow all right so what's the status of
that hypothesis
is it embraced so yeah i mean it's the
best we got
yeah i read it i read it was like yeah
that i'll go with that it's fun to talk
about
and on multiple occasions people said if
i could go anywhere in the universe
where would i go and i said does that
include time and they said sure i said i
want to go back and watch
thea hit the earth yeah
yeah that's cool man so you say it's got
good support by your people
it definitely has good support so we
know that early in the solar system
giant impacts like this were very common
so it makes sense
that this would have happened to us um
and
they would produce moons and and discs
and
the there's other pieces of evidence in
the geological
record so um the moon actually lacks
iron in bulk so what we think happened
is when thea
hit the earth the its core the core of
thea kind of
sank into our earth and what you ended
up having
is the the mantle stuff so the stuff
without the the iron to
to form the moon um and
uh and then the elemental
so then there's the evidence for against
it is
the fact that the moon rocks are so
similar to the ones here on earth
um you would expect that you would see
some evidence of thea
somewhere and we don't so there we do
not have
any evidence of thea um
material here on the here on earth or on
the moon so
we'd have to we have to figure out and
we need an explanation as to why that is
and how
if you found an asteroid stream
around the sun and you looked at its
ingredients and they matched some
combination of earth and the moon
that could be the remains of thea
that's right orbits still orbiting the
sun that is right
but how do you form two objects that are
essentially identical so that would mean
that the moon
that the thea and the earth were very
similar to begin with
and we we have a very hard time with
models
making that happen it's very hard
because when we look
at at other objects other planets
asteroids
everything is really different you can
you can find the fingerprint
for each of these bodies and
we really can't with the earth and the
moon so
so are what other moon in the solar
system comes closest to matching
our own well i guess it depends on what
you're trying what do you mean by
closest so
uh if if you're talking about size so
the moon
is very big compared to the earth
because when you look at other moons in
the solar system the planets are huge
compared to the size of
of um of their moons well it's not only
big compared to earth it's big
compared to anything and anything that's
right all the other if you lined up all
the moons
our moon is like in the top side of that
it's huge absolutely yeah it's it's very
it's a weird
moon is weird yeah but
um pluto i know it's not a planet
uh it has a moon that's back
[Laughter]
uh but it has a moon that is very large
compared to
pluto itself so in that sense it is
similar to our system our earth moon
system is similar to the pluto
sharon system because of the size
the size ratios between the planet and
the moon yeah
okay and how about composition wise is
it are there any moons that are made up
of
like you said basically
like the mantle like you said what is
there any any do we have any evidence of
anything like that
anywhere else yeah there's definitely um
so io is a is a rocky
moon um and it it has
it it has rocks on it so but everything
is very different and when you go out
into the solar system you have more
icy bodies whereas here in the inner
solar system you have
more of the rocky uh moons and planets
of course io is around jupiter yeah okay
all right all right chuck keep going
here we go this is will
uh from twitter he says do you think
there is bacteria still alive
in the apollo missions oh god
leavings i will say uh
the bags that they had to leave uh
if there is none that have survived
what would that mean for future deep
space
travel
so i'm guessing oh i think i know okay i
think i think i know the question okay
yes yes yes so it
they did do that they did leave
bags yeah yes see because you can say
that neil when i say poop bags people go
chuck
chuck okay
these poop bags
describe for me the bacterial
composition of these
thank you neil so so the question was
there do i think there's any bacteria
still alive
bacteria still wait just to be clear
they left it on the surface of the moon
they did wait you have to carry your
poop
out of our national parks or something
what's this some place
there's some places that are so
preserved you can't you can barely pee
on a tree without scraping it off and
taking it out of the park with you and
we can leave poop on the moon i don't
know
these astronauts are like the neighbors
that i have because i live next door to
a doggone dog park
okay they're worse than my neighbors
rachel i i didn't know that okay yeah
yeah yeah so i
if you had a choice would you want to
bring poop back to earth or rocks back
to the air that is true it's a trade-off
isn't it so
you want to bring i'm bringing the rocks
you bring in the rocks so
weight is very important thing when it
comes to space travel and space
exploration
so you're gonna try to maximize
the quality of the weight that you're
actually transporting
um i don't think that there's bacteria
alive so i know that
um the the poop back bags um
had germicidal in in them to actually
kill bacteria so
the the bags themselves i think they had
to tear these pouches and
and pour it into the uh and mix mix
the stuff
and and there's but there's other other
reasons why i don't think it's alive
nothing's alive in there you radiation
is a really big challenge
in in space so it's probably been
completely irradiated from
out there although this is a radiation
because it has no atmosphere to protect
it that's
right anything coming hits the surface
it hits it yeah and
also the heat so the surface of the moon
can get as hot as i think
260 degrees fahrenheit so you
essentially have probably
cooked everything that's baked in the
bag yes
a specialty in some parts getting a
feeling that after this conversation
there'll be
several young people who are like yeah i
don't think i'm going to be an astronaut
oh that's sad no no no we need we need
astronauts yeah
all right um let's see
here this is whoopsie doodle
um you could pronounce that one chuck
good yes you're damn right
finally somebody likes me
uh whoopsie doodle says dr tyson and
raquel
and hi chuck my question is can you
explain what is the dark side of the
moon
so there is no dark side of the moon
next question
but a lot of people don't know that a
lot so we don't have a dark side it's
only a side that we never
see because the moon is tidally locked
to the earth
so but it's not dark it gets it gets
sunlight
um and so gary larson did it right with
the name of his column was the far
side that's right pink floyd got it
wrong where the name of the album was
the dark side
that's right this is the measure of
science literacy here
yeah we call it the far side that's what
we call the what
a lot of people know as the dark side
there you go yeah it's dark to us
all right so uh manuel
uh delgado and it's actually del ghetto
wow delegato there it is manuel delegato
from instagram says in the film
time traveler the moon breaks apart
due to mining what would happen
to the earth if the moon
broke apart by the way that's that's uh
i think
the umbrella academy that that's the
destruction of the earth too
the piece of the moon breaks off and
destroys the earth
but what what what what what would we be
it's also true in the movie melancholia
the the moon approaches earth and then
they collide
and everyone dies my my favorite book
called seven eves
that happens in the first page as well
in the first page of the first page the
moon breaks up
and it picks up from there
and they lived happily ever right
exactly
all right so but what would we what are
we without the moon
it would be a very bad time on earth if
if the moon broke up so the energy
between the pieces breaking up and
hitting each other would
destabilize their orbits and they would
end up crashing into the earth
and that would be bad very very bad as
we know happened to the dinosaurs
um with much smaller pieces with much
smaller p
that yeah so it would the earth we
wouldn't survive
life might not even survive if that were
to happen um
but if you don't even take that into
account so let's we don't worry about
pieces falling into into earth the
the moon provides the earth with a very
stable orbit so
um we don't tilt the earth doesn't tilt
very much because it has the
the moon there to stabilize its orbit so
that's why we have very mild seasons
so if we didn't have the moon there our
seasons would we would have
years thousands of years of ice ages and
then
and life would not survive the same
thing actually happens on on in mars
because mars has small moons they don't
stabilize their orbits so mars is always
tilting over periods of millions of
years and
um yeah so bad bad thing but but but to
be clear
this would not happen if you're just
with normal
mining techniques you don't have enough
energy to actually break up the moon so
we don't have to worry about that unless
they find roku for cheese and they pull
it all out that's half the mass of the
moon
that'll totally just that'll totally
mess up the moon
we confessed earlier in the show you
have to dig very deep to not find cheese
i think you said that in the beginning
of this program did you
what do you think neil if the moon broke
apart like that's
terrible right yeah but i i think that
our access would go unstable on a
period of time longer than civilization
i mean yeah yeah tens of thousands of
years not just a few thousand so
i think the astronomers would love it
because the moon completely messes up
our night sky
we can't see anything when the full moon
is out so i would love it
for the time until we all died it would
be great
that's so funny all right that's funny
yeah well
all right chuck what do you have next
here it is um
this is destin uh destiny from
twitter says what color
is the moon really is it
is it all really gray are there features
in different colors and and why
why okay so uh and then he says chuck's
chuck you get 10 cosmic points if you
say my name
correctly well guess what keep your
points
[Laughter]
because you know damn well uh let's see
uh
okay that's all i can say maybe that
that might be your name
okay okay so what do you have ratel
well it's really interesting is that how
many people think that the moon
is white or this very light gray color
you know when i do
outreach events people and i bring moon
dust with me people i like
whoa it's so dark i thought it was white
and it's not it's actually very dark
thing
in the sky um
when you look up at the night sky you
see these different regions so you have
the dark and the light regions and in
the dark regions those are ancient
volcanic plains so
those rocks are are like black lava
rocks that you see in hawaii or in
iceland
they're they're almost as dark as a
newly paved road
so it's it's very very dark those rocks
are very dark
um and then the the lighter region of
the moon
um those are the highlands so those are
made up of certain minerals that
are lighter but it's still a a dark gray
color
so the fact that the moon is so bright
just means the sun is really bright on
them
that's right that's the only reason and
the other reason is is a relative thing
it when it's in our night sky
we look at it compared to a dark
background so it looks even brighter to
us
so what's around it is darker and that
makes it look brighter
so i i heard that it's uh the moon is a
is basically
as dark as the sidewall of your black
tires
i heard that reflecting just a few
percent of the total sunlight that hits
it
yeah and um i think overall i think it's
about like 13
maybe or twenty percent better even that
high i was thinking
overall overall so because but if you
look at just the dark regions so the the
the lava fields uh those are yeah as
dark as a paved road
yeah yeah it's kind of crazy wow that is
that's really fascinating but just to be
clear
so so the they'll reflect some light
some of the light the rest of the light
it absorbs absorbs
so that would heat up the surface which
is why you get so hot in the daytime
there
that's right it's got to contribute to
that somehow yeah okay
that is so cool that's so cool so now uh
i'm i'm gonna use the saying black as a
moon
is the moon all right i like it
okay all right here we go um
this is pratik kotari um
pratik wants to know this uh what would
it take to make the moon
habitable uh is it possible
for a um
colony in the near future
uh yes you can have colonies uh on the
surface but you have to
uh to mitigate all kinds of issues like
the heat
and the radiation um but there are
there's
there's actually lava tubes on the on
the moon that you can
you can see you can go underground with
colonies
which is really exciting but you cannot
terraform so you cannot change the moon
to give it an atmosphere to have running
water because there's just not enough
gravity to hold
an atmosphere on the moon yeah i don't
think people think actively about that
you know
we take it for granted that there's air
here available for us to breathe
without thinking that the gravity of
earth is keeping the atmosphere
on its surface that's right and so on
the moon
the molecules will just escape
absolutely so you can have maybe very a
very short time where you might have an
atmosphere but
the solar wind and the will just blow it
out of the way
just blow it out and the gravity won't
hold it in place so what you're saying
apart from the dozen things that will
kill you
you can easily just have a colony on the
moon yeah not a problem
ignoring those other complications
that's fine all right
all right chuck barely time for one more
give it to me
okay this is cremav raval who says this
if you were granted full authority and
unlimited resources
what is the one scientific instrument
you would choose to land or send to the
moon to broaden our understanding
go i love it i would not send anything
there i would bring back the samples to
the earth
we can have make much better uh
instruments here
more sensitive instruments then it would
cost too much take too much time to
build instruments to take to the moon
so bring the samples back that's what i
would say answer
good answer i gotta agree with that how
could i not agree with that
yeah we gotta call it quits there and
raquel thank you for being on the show
thank you for having me i love talking
about the moon so yes i guess so that's
why we
picked you out of the that's why we did
this so
we'd be delighted to have you back on
when you get your phd and we can
you can tell us about what your
discoveries were sounds good
in in that effort very good so good luck
with that sometimes you need a little
bit of that too
and and we loved your background it
looks like a showroom from a
catalog and um chuck you know that plant
is fake you just know it just looks fake
like yes it is it is yeah yeah it has to
be it's a completely fake plant right
all the other pants
plants are just like don't talk to that
plant
that's not what i meant chuck but
all right we got to call it quits there
chuck always good to have you oh it's a
pleasure tweeting at chuck nice comic
thank you sir and and raquel you you do
public stuff are you
do you have active social media i mostly
use instagram to do my science
outreach it's this space geologist
but you know
very on the nose
when we come back i want a better
instagram handle than that okay
all right great to have you good luck
thanks this has been star talk cosmic
queries
edition i'm neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist
as always
[Music]